calling in from just down the road with
the Fox Sports football media 2019
symposium getting ready to go down
getting ready to take in everything from
the NFL and that Fox group wants all the
good NFL on Fox analysts to know about
before the 2019 season joining us here
on the Rich Eisen show once again good
friend Charles Davis how are you Charles
I'm doing well rich how are you doing
I'm doing football season I'm doing fine
so let's get right into it
now that Cutler's gone from the NFL is
it is he is he gonna join you oh and and
Burkhardt in the booth Charles we gonna
can we get him back because you know
that was just so fleeting a couple years
ago for you guys it was I have not heard
anything about that you know you and I
both know anything is possible okay but
I'm hearing all I'm hearing Jase is
doing star turns on his on his wife's TV
show where he tends to come in and
disrupt things and steals all scenes yes
he does them mm-hmm but I have not heard
a single thing about him coming back and
wanting to join the booth and and work
with us at least not yet hey I'm getting
ready go to our seminar so I may find
out something there well you are closer
to the OSI than I am right now
physically right now Charles you are
climbing yeah a part of the country all
right so it is you and Burkhart again in
the booth for another season that is my
understanding me and Kevin and then you
know Kenny Albert jumps in when Kevin
that goes to do baseball that's right
during World Series time then back again
yeah I'm lucky to be standing next to
him one more time Charles it's a great
listen it's a great booth and I can't
wait the seasons just right around the
corner I know so I I just sense it's
still the Patriots world and we are rent
payers within it Charles I wonder what
you think just about a month plus away
from the regular season here oh I don't
disagree with that at all rich I think
it's folly for us to think otherwise
frankly every time we think we you know
we've kind of got them on the ropes
what's been a unsuccessful season for
the Patriots has ended in the divisional
playoffs I mean that's that's a lousy
year for them so that
for us to think otherwise is crazy it's
the AFC East is the Patriots we just we
ink ink it in and see if anyone else can
compete for a wild-card they'll take one
of the two first-round byes open weeks
and they go from there yeah and then
look for everything that we think that
they've lost they find ways to fill in
let's be honest about it rich let's just
make it very simple
I'll Vannoy Detroit second-round picks
when the Patriots acquired him did
anyone pencil a minute two Super Bowl
rings and play a significant part of
their defense no but that's how the
Patriots do it yeah and then that's
that's why I was joking last week when
Mike Daniels was released by the Green
Bay Packers you know just a matter of
time until he gets that one year seven
eight million dollar below market level
deal with the Patriots where he'll go to
the Pro Bowl and win the Super Bowl and
and and the I guess the Michigan branch
of the Patriots and in terms of the
Lions went ahead and did that it's just
amazing how New England is now as we all
know populating other parts of of the
NFL landscape that said who do you think
has the best chance of unseating them
coming up this fall well I think that
Kansas City obviously got a huge break
on Tyreke Hill we thought that there
would be a suspension and he would miss
games it doesn't appear that other than
for injury now he will do that and that
just keeps them as super high-powered as
you're going to get on the offensive
side of the ball with him Travis Kelce
and right on down the line and obviously
mahomes triggering all that and I was
joking last week with someone is like
yeah I can't wait to see the first
article written about Patrick mahomes
when around week six or seven he's only
on pace for 40 touchdown passes and
everybody talked about how his play has
fallen off you know because we kind of
threw 50 last year that's where he set
the standard but I think that they are
the the prime ones I think the
Indianapolis Colts there's a lot of
optimism there Andrew Luck helped either
way they played down the stretch but
they are in now
a brutal division and it wasn't long ago
rich we would have laughed at the idea
we called AFC South of brutal division
but it is Tennessee's nine and seven
that makes
last year Houston got back off the deck
after after some injury put
injury-plagued times and they ended up
being the team there indianapolis of
course pressed them and got to the
playoffs last year
and Jacksonville was supposed to be the
team contending for the AFC Championship
and they fell on their face but now they
have their quarterback foals
the defense is back you would expect
them to be pretty pretty serious
contenders too so I would look in that
area as well I think that's going to be
prime prime spots for people to do the
chasing and then of course coming out
the north
Pittsburgh hasn't even really talked
about as much as before because
everyone's focused in and on Cleveland I
just think the silence of the offseason
for Pittsburgh helps them as it did for
Seattle last year and I still think
that's Bert runs that division until
further notice well I mean I said it's
the AFC North is the Ravens to lose that
I think Lamar Jackson is going to
improve in a manner that people do not
think that he can because of the way
that he threw the football last year or
didn't throw the football last year and
then all of a sudden over the weekend
you know Brian Billick is on the NFL
Network you know chit-chatting with John
Harbaugh talking about you know
potentially 150 carries for Lamar
Jackson this year and Harbaugh joke
saying take the over and I'm like wow oh
wow yeah I know right so I don't know
how you could take out right because he
mentioned he mentioned that Cam Newton
the most Cam Newton ran a ball during
the season and that that number was high
it was about 150 160 and Harbaugh said
take the old yeah Charles well here's
the thing he's gonna challenge
conventional wisdom cam has already done
that because of those types of you know
workloads and carries right but cam also
physique wise at six what six five six
six whatever you want to call it 250 you
know he's built a little bit different
for that workload right and he's one of
their best short regarded runners that's
what they've done with him with Lamar
that's a different body type but he is
also a guy that's used to understand
where
it's come from how they happened but I
just think you are really challenging
conventional wisdom and maybe they'll
break it and give us something new and
let's say he does go over 150 and stays
healthy through the year now we'll start
searching for more of them are Jackson's
out there and more quarterback run game
would be a little bit more like ouch
another aspect of the college game
creeping into the pros rich if indeed
that happens I will tell you I would be
skeptical of running him that much again
and again and again if that's your
starting quarterback cams cam has been a
whole different animal
Kent Lamar Jackson joining him in that
in that Club well if they're gonna
actually challenge it we'll find out
won't we I again as I said I'm a little
skeptical about that one I wouldn't go
that but I wouldn't go that far with him
especially since you went out and
acquired Mark Ingram yeah I've got a
heavy workload guy Gus Edward gave him
runs last year right I don't know that I
would go that far with my starting
quarterback Charles Davis Fox Sports may
also my compadre from the NFL Network
will sit next to me at drafts etc right
here on the the Rich Eisen show exactly
so hard knock starts August 6th I can't
wait our buddy Mayock I think is going
to set the record for trying to be the
most scarce general manager in the
history of that franchise we were saying
the other day right here Charles you'll
like this because you're mr. pop culture
to that Brockman are saying like that
you know that's shot from the town where
somebody's in a mask is spray-painting
over the security cameras like that yeah
that's Mayock for this this uh what do
you think what do you think Charles I
love that yeah I think that Mike will
actually have someone else in the Mayock
family in the mask spray-painting
because he is the GM now and he won't
have his fingerprints on it at all but
it's gonna be someone you know they've
buried in his past that he'll pull out
one of his guys to do that but once that
camera does find him
it could be pure gold you can run from
it as much as you want I know but you
you and I both know that they've come in
with it with a hit list of who they
expect to be a big part of this and Mike
and John head the list yeah and then
they'll work from there
and I
I can't wait I absolutely positively
cannot wait and those you know the the
requisite bringing the guy in to cut him
time frame yeah that'll be interesting
as heck it's gonna have to handle all
that I'm not sure John won't be doing
that part of it would be more Mike now
to be very that'll be that it may be
pure pure gold you know those gels
sitting there eagerly waiting for it
Charles you know Mayock probably when he
if he is intimating c'mon guys you know
like you know what water I gotta have
the camera in my face come on guys we
really gonna put the microphone there
Mike probably knows the the microphone
person the the camera yep person the
producer by name he might know them by
name because of how much time I see NFL
films in his life you know so yeah it's
amazing what if we had told him years
ago on the set hey Mike you're gonna be
the GM of a team one day and your first
summer as GM is gonna be chronicled by
Hard Knocks what do you think Oh God
look and that's near the worst part you
might be right but the second part there
is no way that's going to happen but you
also go back no way with Gruden - right
like what's your history with Joey yeah
Charles John's first job coaching with
he's a ga a graduate assistant coach in
his first jobs as University of
Tennessee that was my last year playing
as my fifth year I was a redshirt senior
and we lived on the same floor for that
year so that's where we first got to
know each other and then we coached
together the University of the Pacific
and were roommates for 1415 months
somewhere in that timeframe so so when
you put all that together you know I go
back a ways with him and that's why you
know when people always talk about you
know John work at it getting up at 3:16
3:17 in the morning blah blah there's a
lot of skepticism as you might imagine
rich people like no one does that I
witnessed it so I know it happens I know
this is real when when when that clock
goes off because he used to come wake me
up and then and every time I tell go
away
like what are you doing is 320 something
in the morning and he's like look look
coach here's how it's gonna go down
we're gonna go for a run and then we're
gonna come back we're gonna shower we're
gonna stop in a little corner place I'm
gonna get a big gulp of a big thing a
coffee you're gonna get whatever it is
you want to drink when I get to the
office we get to work he said we're
gonna by the time everyone else gets to
the office we'll be a half day ahead of
them now you add up all those half days
you know where we are we're way ahead so
let's get moving
the next thing you know I'm out there
running the streets of Stockton
California John we're going by we're
getting the coffee and what-have-you
we're in the office and we're just going
to work and you see how he parlayed that
and turned that work ethic and
production into the Jon Gruden we know
today so anyone who wants to tell me
well there's no way that could happen I
just laugh at almost like oh it happened
and it happened every day and I
experienced it so I learned you know I
think I had a good work ethic rich yeah
but when you're around a guy like Gruden
it gets honed in ways like you would
never expect and I'm never getting that
amount of sleep I lost back that I know
for sure that's fantastic
charles davis here in the Rich Eisen
show a couple more minutes left with you
Charles all right Charles on Friday
shows you know Mike dill 2fo my my sound
man here my audio executive pardon me
Mike I didn't mean to downgrade you the
executive and I had a moment here on the
show and I'd love for you to tell me
what you think is more likely I looked
at del Tufo with his callaway hat on his
head and I said I would eat that hat if
Ezekiel Elliott was healthy healthy
human being on planet earth and wasn't
the starting running back of the Dallas
Cowboys week one despite all the
contractual stuff going on and he said
he would eat that hat if Rob Gronkowski
played it all in 2019 which one of us
charles davis is more likely to eat a
hat this fall I actually think actually
think Mike you know I love you but I
actually think you bring it to salt and
pepper no way to be there week one and
playing and I just think that out of the
two bets it's much more likely that
somehow Brady stalks Gronk into making a
stretch run
you think I think so that's just the way
this is where I go with it
the Cowboys know what they have to do
and remember Stephen Jones will have to
own and I don't think he Minds this but
hops to own taking Reggie Jackson's
quote and applying it to Zeke he's the
straw that stirs our drink I know that
he's third in line or whatever for the
contract but he's first in line and how
the Cowboys play on offense so - the
Commissioner having another visit with
Zeke I just think that they're gonna
find a way to get that done because your
window for Super Bowls
you can't pull Stephen Strasburg and
shut them down early and say we'll get
them next year you got to go for it
every single year I think I think Zeke
is is the way for Dallas and I think the
Dallas knows that excellent analogy
using what happened with Strasburg in
the Nats years ago so salt and pepper
ketchup mic time you know it's more
likely for you than it is for me is
basically you know I love you making it
do you want but you're more likely and
and wouldn't that be something if both
of them came true you know what I don't
think Zeke is sitting out week one I
think you're right they're gonna figure
out a way don't either
Stephen Jones needs to ask his dad how'd
that work out with Emmett missed in the
first two day two games well and Jerry
could say what we won the Super Bowl
anyway that said that's not my point
it was not a fun hole they went oh and -
we didn't play oh yeah that's why Emmett
came in and they got a double I am again
Desmond Charles Haley put that helmet
imprint into the locker room wall when
he hurled it across the thing screaming
get em it in here hey before I let you
go I know you got to get to your
symposium tell me about the extech
shoulder pads that you're involved with
Charles yeah you know Bob Broderick and
Ted moniker the cofounders of these and
rich they were kind of a niche company
when it first started and now they are a
monster if you look it up and check it
out now the players going into 2019 a
voted X Tech the number one shoulder pad
in the game and a lot of its motivated
by our playing now we're taking the head
out of the game rich shoulders are way
more important these things are custom
built you know form fitting for these
guys guys like Quentin Nelson they're
wearing them you know Andrew Luck's
wearing them and memories coming back
from shoulder issues it's a big deal
Ryan throws passes in them you know an
Eli banning you got some big time
players oh yeah
Khalil Maxim's people with them too so
these pads are the best things I think
on the market and continuing to grow
what Ted and Bob have done in creating
the shoulder pad company and taking it
to the masses 400 plus college that's
300 plus high schools you know the pro
teams gaining momentum I actually did
this last week rich and a friend called
me from Minnesota and said I heard you
talk about X Tech that is so cool my
high school just bought them for the
entire team so I know that they're
taking off a crazy momentum but go to X
tech comm check out the promos and promo
opportunities that are there and if you
have a kid if you have someone you care
about put them in those pads I put my
son in them hits in your eyes go up her
shoulder troubles his junior year did
not miss the snap to senior year I think
these things are the best things on the
market X tech pads calm or at xx tech
pads on Instagram hey Charles thanks for
the call really appreciate it
do me a favor take a photo snap a pic of
the PowerPoint screen grab that they're
gonna put up on maybe maybe it is Eric
shanks is in charge of Fox Sports
showing how their ratings go up when
Mike del 2 pho is doing the audio for a
game can you snap that be right out of
the gate
thanks I'm sure it'll be first up on the
agenda for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app